oxidiser to power falcon 9 currently our
few 1 and lakhs are nearly fully loaded
on both stages and lakhs will continue
to be topped off right until the last
minute of the countdown the stack of 60
satellites is safely enclosed inside of
the 17 foot diameter payload fairing
which you can see on your screen that's
that pointed structure at the very top
of the rocket this protects the
satellites from the arrow thermal
heating aerodynamic loads and
contamination during ascent but once we
reach the vacuum of space we no longer
need them so we will jettison the
fairing as the second stage continues on
its journey to orbit we will be
attempting to recover the fairing halves
today using our recovery ships mystery
and mischeif at approximately t plus 40
minutes the team will perform a poll to
confirm if we're all good to make a
catch attempt and weather plays a factor
as well as telemetry of the fairing its
altitude position and speed and we were
watching some thick clouds earlier
making sure that we are good for weather
just like we did in last week's launch
demo to launch constantly checking on
the weather but today we are currently
go for weather at t0 so with that the
vehicle satellites weather and range are
all looking good for an on-time liftoff
just about five and a half minutes from
now and as I mentioned at the top of the
broadcast we are coming off an amazing
weekend with the SpaceX and NASA teams
successfully launching the dads at NASA
astronauts Bob bacon and Doug Hurley to
the International Space Station
our second demonstration mission or what
we call demo two lifted off from
historic launch pad 39a at Kennedy Space
Center on Saturday May 30th and 19 hours
later docked with the International
Space Station the mission marks the
first time a commercially built
spacecraft has launched people to the
space station and the first time in
nearly ten years that the US has
launched astronauts into space from US
soil the video that you see on your
screen is Bob
and Doug floating around in orbit giving
us a tour of their Dragon spacecraft
which they named endeavour to
commemorate the huge efforts made by the
SpaceX team as well as a nod to the
first shuttle that they both flew on
demo2 is an end-to-end flight test from
a launch to docking to splashdown it is
the final major milestone for SpaceX s
human spaceflight system to be certified
by NASA for operational crew missions to
and from the International Space Station
while Bob and Doug certainly had the
best seats for the demo to launch they
weren't the only ones to try their hand
at docking dragon to the space station
we recently released the same simulation
that the astronauts trained on in
advance of the demo2 mission head over
to ISS - sim dot SpaceX comm - give it a
try yourself that simulation the
displays and crew dragon and a bunch of
other really cool projects were
developed by SpaceX software engineers
software engineers at SpaceX get to work
across exciting projects that drive our
rockets spacecraft satellites and ground
systems if you're interested in helping
roll out star link to the world or
taking humanity to the moon in Mars
send your resume to software jobs at
SpaceX comm we will also be setting up a
reddit ask me anything or AMA with our
software team in the next week or so so
stay tuned to our social media accounts
for details on that once demo2 is
complete these SpaceX and NASA teams
have reviewed all the data for
certification NASA astronauts Victor
Glover Mike Hopkins Shannon Walker and
JAXA astronaut soluti Noguchi have been
assigned to fly on dragons first
six-month operational mission which were
calling crew one which is targeted for
later this year we are currently two and
a half minutes from liftoff and Falcon 9
is now moving into the final stages of
the countdown the first and second
stages are both nearly fully loaded with
1 million pounds of kerosene fuel and
liquid oxygen super chilled liquid
oxygen which as I mentioned
earlier is our propellant oxidizer is
what's creating those white clouds that
you see around Falcon 9 when it's
exposed to the warmer ambient air then
you could see that on your screen there
first stage should finish prop loading
actually already has finished prop
loading at t-minus three minutes and
second stage is coming up on finished
prop loading at t-minus two minutes at
t-minus 60 seconds Falcon 9 will be in
startup and that means that the Rockets
autonomous internal flight computers
have taken over the launch countdown so
with the StarLink payload continuing to
be healthy the f9 teams Falcon 9 teams
are tracking no issues on the rocket
weather is still looking good and the
range is green for launch so we are at
t-minus one and a half minutes from
liftoff and again in about 30 seconds
Falcon 9 will be in start-up what this
means is that the vehicle will basically
be autonomously making its decision if
it will continue with liftoff at t0
Falcon I didn't start up and there's
that call out that Falcon 9 is in start
up over lunch and at t-minus 45 seconds
there was that call out for go for lunch
again that was the Falcon 9 rocket
making that decision autonomously now we
are t-minus 30 seconds from liftoff of
our star link payload tonight so let's
listen in and watch liftoff five four
three two one
yeah
[Music]
nice together
we are t+ 40 seconds into flight and
Falcon 9 has successfully lifted up from
pad 40 at Cape Canaveral Air Force
Station carrying our sterling payload -
its targeted dropped off orbit moments
ago we did throttle down our engines in
preparation for max Q and that is the
maximum aerodynamic pressure which is
the largest structural load that the
vehicle will see that's coming up here
in a few seconds XQ and there's that
call-out that we have just passed
through max Q in about a minute we will
have three events happening back to back
the first of which will be main engine
cutoff or Mikko this is where all nine
m1d engines shut off to slow the vehicle
down in preparation for the second event
which is stage separation stage
separation is where the first stage
separates from the second stage with the
first stage the first stage starting to
make its way back to earth for landing
and stage two continuing on its journey
with the third event called SES one or
second engine start one and that's where
the n-back engine lights up on the
second stage and propels the second
stage along with the StarLink satellites
to its drop-off orbit orbits we are at t
plus two minutes and five seconds so
we're just about 25 seconds away from
those three events again that is Niko
stage separation and s.vs one or second
engines start one
ego stage separation confirmed and there
you can see on your screen on the left
screen we had main engine cutoff and
stage separation on your right screen is
the second stage and back engine
lighting up glowing bright red there and
it is a bit dark on the East Coast but
you can see on your left screen that
first stage those grid fins are
deploying and on your right screen we
have fairing deploy coming upstairs and
there is that confirmation of fairing
deploy now let's see if those fairing
halves can be recovered by a recovery
ships mystery and mischief today again
we won't have that live that will happen
around t plus 40 minutes so check in
with our social media accounts for
updates on those bearing halves
and stage 2 still looking nominal again
that is what you see on your right
screen stage 1 is making its way back
and as the first stage makes its way
back to earth it will perform at 2 burns
the first of which will be the entry
burn and that is where three of the nine
m1g engines read Knight and this helps
slow the vehicle down as it reenters
back into the upper part of the Earth's
atmosphere and finally will be the
second and final burn is the landing
burn and this is a single engine burn
that's the center a nine engine that
reignites and brings the vehicle all the
way down on very very rapidly slows the
vehicle down so that it can touch down
and land on the drone ship again we are
attempting to land the first stage today
on just read the instructions as are of
course I still love you drone ship was
occupied with her demo two vehicle from
over the weekend up until last night
we are at t plus five and a half minutes
stage two still looking nominal and
first stage making its way back that
first burn that entry burn will be
coming up in about a minute from now
around t plus six minutes and 45 seconds
and that entry burn will last about 20
seconds long again that is to slow the
vehicle down as it re-enters back into
the Earth's atmosphere
Stage two on your right screen still on
a nominal trajectory and on your left
screen it is a little bit dark it is
nighttime on the East Coast but we
should see that screen light up with
those with that entry burn those three
engines reigniting stage 1 ft ssafe
stage one entry baron has started and
there you hear that call out as well as
a visual confirmation that those engines
have reignited the vehicle continues to
follow a nominal trajectory and stage 1
etchebarren shut down and confirmation
that the stage one entry burn is
complete as well as stage 2 still
looking nominal you heard that call out
coming up next is the landing burn
around t plus eight and a half minutes
around eight minutes and 24 seconds
looks like we lost that live view of the
first stage coming down but that is
expected hopefully we can get that live
view back right now you'll see right now
what you're seeing on your left screen
is the drone ship just read the
instructions followed very closely after
the landing burn and landing of the
first stage will be Seco one that is
second engine cutoff around t plus eight
minutes and 58 seconds
Stage one landing burn has started
landing legs have deployed days to FTS
sh t and Wow as you coming 100 on
recovery one amazing that first stage
booster has landed for the first time
for the fifth time for a falcon 9
booster that is amazing we're waiting
for a second stage engine cutoff what an
amazing view of that first stage coming
down even though it was dark and night
but those engines lighting up the screen
watching first stage come down was an
amazing view and we heard a call out of
good orbit for a second stage
acquisition of signal inland and now
that second stage is going to now that
second stage isn't a good orbit it's
going to coast for a few minutes and
during this time it will start to spin
along its central axis getting these
sterling satellites the momentum that
they need to space themselves out over
time after they deploy so we will take a
quick break and return back here at t
plus 14 minutes
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to the webcast for StarLink
so far we had an on-time liftoff tonight
stage once successfully separated from
stage two and made its way back to land
on our drone ship just read the
instructions which was the first time a
booster has landed for a fifth time in
SpaceX history so very exciting stage
two is still nominal and now we are
coming up on deployment of the StarLink
satellite shortly here in about 40
seconds or so and we firmly believe in
the importance of a naturalist night sky
for all of us to enjoy which is why we
have been working with leading
astronomers around the world to better
understand the specifics of their
observations and engineering changes we
can make to reduce satellite brightness
what a measure we're taking to
accomplish this is by adding a
deployable visor to the satellites to
block sunlight from hitting the
brightest parts of the spacecraft now
let's listen in to that call out for
payload deploy and again the first unit
with the Sun Visor is actually on this
payload right here that you see in front
of you
politically confirmed and there is that
confirmation we got a live view as it
was deploying from the vehicle
those Starling satellites are making
their way separating from second stage
right in front of you right now shortly
they will deploy their solar array and
over the next few days and weeks they
will distance themselves from each other
and use their onboard ion thrusters to
make their way to their operational
orbits and also just to note tomorrow is
June 4th that was actually the
anniversary of our first Falcon flight
10-year anniversary of our first flights
a very exciting time
first Falcon 9 flight so very very
exciting times and that brings our
webcast to a closed follow our website
and social media platforms for updates
on our next missions and milestones and
as the work goes on to build a better
more exciting future please stay safe
stay healthy and we'll see you at the
next launch
[Music]